ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE HEARING FOR
NON FISCAL AND URGENCY
LEGISLATION TODAY WILL HEAR
WHAT URGENCY MEASURE AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED BY EDUARDO GARCIA AND
MULLIN. A FEW REMINDERS WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
MASKS ARE REQUIRED AT ALL TIMES
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL AND THE
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
OUTSIDE. TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL
NEAR THE NORTH STEPS AND BY
PHONE THE NUMBER FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THIS NUMBER IS POSTED ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND
ALSO APPEARS ON THE VIDEO FEED.
ONCE THE PRIMARY SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TESTIFIED I WILL CALL FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY TO REDUCE DELAYS
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
COMBINED INTO A SINGLE Q.
TESTIMONY WILL BE LIMITED AS
FOLLOWS. EACH PRIMARY SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION WITNESS WILL BE
GIVEN TWO MINUTES ADDITIONAL ME
TO TESTIMONY WILL BE LIMITED TO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY OF ANY
LENGTH MAY BE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE VIA OUR WEBSITE A. N.
T. R. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV. OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- IF THE AUTHOR WOULD
LIKE TO COME UP AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED. OR OR THE AUTHORS THE
JOINT AUTHORS. THIS. PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND START WHEN THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
JOIN AUTHOR MR GARCIA WILL BE
JOINING US UP MOMENTARILY. WE
ARE FACING THE CHALLENGE OF OUR
ERA. AS THE EVOLVING CLIMATE
CRISIS THREATENS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT EVERY DAY. HOWEVER
WE ARE IN AN ESPECIALLY UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE AS WE ARE ALSO
FACING A GLOBAL HEALTH CRISIS
THAT IS BECAUSE OUR STATE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE TO LINGER AT
DOUBLE THE RATE OF MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY. RIGHT BEFORE
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS WERE
ISSUED. TO COMBAT BOTH OF THESE
DILEMMAS CALIFORNIA NEEDS A
CREATIVE SOLUTION AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED WILL REBUILD OUR WORK
FORCE IN PROTECT OUR STATE
AGAINST FUTURE CLIMATE RELATED
DISASTERS. THAT UNLIKE COVERT
NINETEEN WE KNOW ARE COMING
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
PLACE A SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
BOND ON THE JUNE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BALLOT TO FINANCE VARIOUS
CLIMATE ADAPTATION ACTIVITIES.
WHICH CREATE LONG TERM GREEN
JOBS THAT HELP US REACH OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND FRANKLY IT'S
A MODEST DOWN PAYMENT GIVEN THE
SCALE OF THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
ARE FACING AS A STATE. AS THE
NEED FOR EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
EFFORTS RISE IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT WE INVEST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES.
ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMY FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS AND
MADAM CHAIR I'VE- I THINK I'VE
BEEN MOTIVATED BY THE MAGNITUDE
OF THE CHALLENGE THAT WE ARE
FACING WE CAN'T AFFORD TO SIT
BACK JUST IN MY REGION ALONG
THE BAY AREA OVER A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS- IS AT RISK.
AND TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
AT RISK JUST IN MY COUNTY SO
SEVEN BILLION REPRESENTS A
MODEST APPROACH WE ARE GOING TO
BE HEARING IN JUST A BIT FROM
ADRIAN COVERT- WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL AS WELL AS RICO
MASTRODONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND ON THE LINE- BUT-
BEFORE WE DO THAT LET ME TURN
IT OVER TO. OUR JOINT AUTHOR
AND REALLY THE LEAD ON THIS
EFFORT OF COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA. THANK YOU-
COLLEAGUE INTO MEDICARE.
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE- I
DON'T THINK I NEED TO ELABORATE
MORE ON THE REASONS WHY THE
BOND IS NECESSARY I'LL JUST SAY
THAT- THERE IS A SENSE OF
URGENCY ON ALL OF OUR PARTS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- MORE SO. WHEN WE
LOOK AT PARTICULAR AREAS WHERE
NOW THE GOVERNOR HAS DECLARED A
DROUGHT. AND THE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT THAT THAT WILL HAVE
STATEWIDE- I'D LIKE TO JUST
POINT TO. ONE OF THE TOP
REASONS WHY THIS BOND HAS COME
FORWARD. AB LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA'S WORSE FIRE SEASON
ON RECORD WITH OVER FOUR POINT.
TWO MILLION ACRES BURNED.
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF LOSS WHEN
IT COMES TO LIFE. AND PROPERTY.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TO DO BETTER WE HAVE TO DO
MORE. IN NOW IS THE TIME. AS
WAS MENTIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE
IN A CO EQUAL PARTNER HERE. HI
THIS IS A DOWN PAYMENT. AND WE
HAVE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY ALSO
WITH THE BUDGET SURPLUS THAT IS
BEFORE US. TO MAKE SOME
ADVANCEMENTS. IN THE AREAS THAT
WE HAVE OUTLINED AS PRIORITY IN
THIS BOND SO. I DON'T KNOW THAT
THE QUESTION WOULD BE EITHER
OR- BUT I THINK GIVEN THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A DOWN
PAYMENT HAS BEEN MENTIONED. ARE
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
MORE- WITH THAT- RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU-
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND I'D LIKE TO.
THE SECRETARY TO TAKE THE ROLE.
MEMBERS RIVAS. HERE RIVAS HERE
FLORA FLORA CARE CHAU. FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN HERE GARCIA GARCIA
HERE MATHIS. MATHIS HERE
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI SAY OUR
DOCTOR SAY OUR JOB HERE STONE.
WOOD WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU SO WE'RE READY FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES RECALL MUST OR
NOT- FROM THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND AND ADRIAN COVERT FROM
PUBLIC POLICY BAY AREA COUNCIL-
I'D LIKE TO REMIND THE
WITNESSES THAT YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES A MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND I
BELIEVE THEIR LINES ARE UP AT
THIS POINT. BUT MORE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. UP
UP IT STARTED TO KNOW WHO WITH
THE RIGHT PART- GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND- BOND
AUTHORS RECALL MONSTER TOMATO
WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND-
WERE OBVIOUSLY IN FULL SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED- AND JUST
TO ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT ON
WHAT THE AUTHORS THAT. I WOULD
THINK. FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
EVERYTHING SCIENCE WARNED US
ABOUT THIS COMING TRUE. WORST
WILDFIRES EVER LAST YEAR ALL OF
OUR READ THE BOARDS ARE AT 50%
AND ARTWORK FACING ANOTHER
CATASTROPHIC DROUGHT TWENTY
TWENTY WHAT THE HOTTEST YEAR ON
RECORD AND AUGUST THROUGH-
OCTOBER IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT THE
HOTTEST IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY-
THE BOND ADDRESSES WILDFIRES
BOTH THE NOTES AND DRINKING
WATER WILDLIFE HABITS THAT. ARE
FARMERS AND ANNA AND
AGRICULTURE. REGIONAL CLIMATE
RESISTANCE BUT I'M GOING TO
FOCUS ON SOMETHING MADAM CHAIR
I KNOW YOU CARE ABOUT WHICH IS
EXTREME HEAT. THE STATE HAVE NO
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR WORK
PROGRAM THAT ADDRESSES THE
CLIMATE RELATED IMPACTS OF
EXTREME HEAT. AND HELP ONLY TO
NATURE BASED PROGRAMS THAT.
EVEN A DRAFT THAT YOU ARE URBAN
GREENING AND URBAN FORESTRY-
BOTH HAVE BEEN GROSSLY UNDER
FUNDED- AND URBAN GREENING
DIDN'T GET ANY MONEY AND THE
BUDGET IN JANUARY- THEY ARE
REPRESENTED IN THIS BOND ALONG
WITH THE AB THIRTY ONE PROGRAM-
AND THAT'S AGAIN IT'S DESPITE
THE REALITY OF WHAT WE
EXPERIENCED LAST YEAR AND WHAT
SCIENCE IS TELLING US- HE PUTS
MORE PEOPLE IN THE HOSPITAL.
AND KILLED SOME FRANKLY THAN
ANY OTHER WELL WEATHER RELATED-
BENT. AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA- THERE WERE SURFACE
TEMPERATURES RIGHT THERE AND-
THE- THE EAST END OF THE COUNTY
WHERE YOUR- DISTRICT AND- CHAIR
REBATES. THAT WERE SURFACE
TEMPERATURES THAT ARE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DEGREES PEOPLE CAN'T
SURVIVE IN THE WORLD THAT- IF
COMIC. ESPECIALLY IF THERE ARE
NO GREEN SPACES NO TREE CANOPY.
AND WE HAVE DENSELY POPULATED
URBAN AREAS WHERE HEAT ISLANDS
ARE FOCUSED LIKE YOU. HAVE A
MAGNIFYING GLASS ON. SO I
STRONGLY AND YOU THIS. AT THE
GET THE MAN WE BACK URKE THING
ON TO- IS. A LAW GERMAN FOR
GREENING. BUT THIS FONG I DO
WE'VE ALL OF THE PRIORITY I
THANK THOSE PRIOR SHOULD BE.
ALSO REPRESENTED IN THE BUDGET-
THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE URGENCY- BUT
THIS IS OUR- A GREAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THOUGHTFULLY PUT
TOGETHER BY BOTH AUTHORS BUT I
WANT TO THANK THEM- Ë
OF THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND
AND- AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA
FRANKLY FOR THE STOP- AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AND WITH THAT AYE
RICHER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MALIK
GARCIA HI NEED HEARING COVERAGE
WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL ON
BEHALF OF THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
THEIR EXAMPLES PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
WITHIN THE PAST SEVEN YEARS
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY VOLATILE
CLIMATE HAS SHATTERED
LONGSTANDING CLIMATE RECORDS
RELATED TO DROUGHT WILDFIRE
HEAT AND FLOODS. THESE
DISASTERS DAMAGE ECOSYSTEMS DAY
HURT ECONOMIES AND THEY DISRUPT
AND TOO OFTEN COST HUMAN LIVES
THE TWENTY TWELVE THROUGH
TWENTY SIXTEEN DROUGHT OUR MOST
RECENT DROUGHT BEFORE THE ONE
WE'RE CURRENTLY AND COST THREE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC LOSSES AND NEARLY
THIRTY THOUSAND JOBS THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WILD FIRES
ALONE COST NEARLY A HUNDRED
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC LOSSES AND ALL OVER A
HUNDRED DEATHS. AND IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A RECORD OF UP TO
TWELVE YEAR COST NEARLY A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
FLOOD DAMAGES IN SAN JOSE
ALLOWED TO NEARLY TOPPLED THE
OROVILLE DAM SPILLWAY AND AS
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER MENTIONED
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY WAS THE
HOTTEST MONTH IN STATE HISTORY
EXTREME HEAT IS CAUSING
INCREASED- PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT ALTHOUGH THEN
SCROLLING BLACKOUTS AND AROUND
FORTY THAT'S ON AVERAGE EACH
YEAR. AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED WOULD
INVEST SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
UPGRADING AND IMPROVING THE
RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
NEIGHBORHOODS BUSINESSES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ECOSYSTEMS
D. EASE- AND PREPARE AND DEFEND
AGAINST THESE AND OTHER CLIMATE
RELATED CHALLENGES AND IN DOING
SO AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED WOULD NOT
ONLY HELP SAVE LIVES AND AVOID
COSTLY DAMAGES FROM CLIMATE
RELATED DISASTERS IT WOULD ALSO
HELP CREATE JOBS STIMULATE
GROWTH IMPROVING ECOSYSTEM
HEALTH AND PROTECT COMMUNITIES.
ACCORDING TO ANALYSIS CONDUCTED
BY THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
ECONOMIC INSTITUTE AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED WOULD SUPPORT THE
CREATION. OF APPROXIMATELY A
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND JOHN. AND
THEIR POINT FOUR BILL DOLLAR IN
I CAN ACT OF CALIFORNIA ACROSS
THE BOARD LYFT. PUTTING PEOPLE
TO WORK TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT IS AN
AMERICAN TRADITION GOING BACK
TO THE NEW DEAL AND THE MOST
RECENT POLLING SHOWS A STRONG
MAJORITY CALIFORNIANS WOULD
SUPPORT A CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BOND. TIED TO JOB GROWTH THAT
THIS ONE IS THANK YOU FOR MY
COMMENTS- PREDICT MY COMMENTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. ABOUT. THANK YOU- NEXT WILL
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE ONE- ROBERT REID. SENT
FROM THE CENTRAL OF
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD CONTROL ASSOCIATION AND I
BELIEVE HE'S HERE IN PERSON AND
THE HEARING ROOM. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS- THANK YOU
FOR THE INTRODUCTION SELLING
MEMBER RIVAS- THIS CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL VALLEY FLOOD CONTROL
ASSOCIATION AS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED- MAKE NO MISTAKE
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL A LOT
OF IMPORTANT FUNDING FOR MANY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS AND YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THAT SUPPORT
WITNESSES ABOUT HEAT AND
DROUGHT. AND IN IN CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT THIS BILL IS SORELY
LACKING IN FUNDING THAT WE NEED
FOR THE OPPOSITE OF THOSE AND
THAT'S FROM THE WINTER TIME
WHEN WE WILL ALL SEE IT
INCREASINGLY- OCCURRENCES OF
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS THAT REALLY
BLAST IN THE CALIFORNIA. AND
DUMP A LOT OF WATER INTO A
SYSTEM THAT WAS DESIGNED TO
CAPTURE SNOWMELT. AND SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE INCREASING PRESSURE
ON THE STATE PLAN A FLOOD
CONTROL IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY%
WHICH HAS SIXTEEN HUNDRED MILES
OF LEVEES BYPASSES AND WEIRS
THAT ARE IN MANY CASES- NOT
ADEQUATE TO PROTECT THE LIVES
AND PROPERTY WE'VE GOT ABOUT
OVER ONE MILLION PEOPLE AND
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED. BILLION
DOLLARS IN DAMAGE WILL PROPERTY
INCLUDING THE AREA AROUND THIS
BUILDING THAT ARE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO FLOODS. THIS WOULD BE THE
THIRD BOND MEASURE IN A ROW-
PROP ONE PROP SIXTY EIGHT IN
THIS BILL THAT DON'T PUT
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING INTO OUR
FACILITIES FOR STATE PLAN FLOOD
CONTROL. THE BILL THE BILL ONLY
HOUSE- THE LAST SIGNIFICANT
MONEY CAME FROM PROPOSITION ONE
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO. WE STILL HAVE LEVEES
IN OUR SYSTEM THAT WERE DAMAGED
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN WINTER
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN REPAIRED.
THEY'RE CURRENTLY ORPHAN SITES
THAT FEMA DIDN'T DECIDE TO TAKE
UP- THE REPAIRS FOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES
HAVEN'T HASN'T HAD SUFFICIENT
FUNDING TO DEAL WITH THOSE.
THIS BILL DOESN'T CLUED ANY
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS- THAT ARE
IN AB SEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY SOME
MEMBER DALY IN ORANGE COUNTY AB
NINE TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY FOR WEST
SACRAMENTO SB FOUR NINETY SIX
FOR CENTER LATER IN THE PAHAR
RIVER- WHICH HAS A- PROPOSED
1100% STATE COSTS FOR THAT
FLOOD PROJECT. IT IS INCLUDE
ANY MONEY FOR CENTER ADMINS IN
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILIP WHO
WAS MAS STILL TRACKED DOWN AND
IN THE STOCKTON AREA. SO WHAT
ARE WE ASKING FOR WE'VE
SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE WITH-
WRITTEN PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR DELTA LEVEES. FOR
MULTI BENEFIT PROJECTS WHICH
THIS BILL WOULD INCLUDE. FOR
FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS TO
PROTECT URBAN AREAS OUTSIDE OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND FOR
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
LEVEE SYSTEMS IN THE FACILITIES
THE STATE PLAN FLOOD CONTROL
THE STATE'S OWN CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION PLAN. CALLS
FOR INVESTMENT FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL FUNDS OF UPWARDS OF
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
NEXT TWENTY YEARS. THIS BILL
INCLUDES ABOUT ONE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR. MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS NOT AREAS SO WE REALLY
WANT TO ENGAGE WITH THE AUTHORS
AND WITH THE LEGISLATURE IS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR FLOOD
CONTROL FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION- I'D LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES THAT WE ARE ONLY TAKING.
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU FIRST WE
WILL GO TO LINE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THERE'S ONLY ONE
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
SURE LIKE YOU'RE TEACHING
DISTRICT AND EMPTY CLEAN ENERGY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NINE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHOPPING PLAY
CALLING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO ALSO WITH
THE SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION- THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BECAUSE PARKS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU.
AND LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JUST HIGHER
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF COMMENDED
POSITIONS FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE FORWARD. AND OVER LINE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO DRIVE ME THROUGH
THICK YEAH BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FOREST FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AMEX HAVE
LIKE TWENTY SIX GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ALL NEIGHBORHOODS OF
COURSE CRACKLE CAULAINCOURT.
AND NEXT BLANK TWENTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MA'AM CHAIR RUSS BUT
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. GOOD LINE TWENTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS
FIFTY MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AVIAN.
IN A POSITION OF SUPPORT IF
AMENDED TO INCLUDE A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
PROJECTS WITH CULTURAL
HISTORICAL RESOURCES THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING JULIE MALINOVSKY
BALL ON BEHALF OF GENESIS EARLY
WARNING SYSTEMS IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED. LIKE NAKED
LINE TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
SURE MEMBERS OR ANY OTHER
STORIES TO WITH THE WHITEMAN%
GROUP ON BEHALF OF BLOOM ENERGY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
APPLYING. TWENTY GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADDED
COMMUNITIES ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE HAVE A SUPPORT
AMENDED POSITION JUST **** THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER MORE
FUNDING FOR WATER RESILIENCE
GIVEN THIS A HISTORIC DROUGHT.
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE FIFTEEN
IF I HAD. FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BONTA LINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
MARTIN RADAKOVICH ON BEHALF OF
THE TREE CARE INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TASHA NEWMAN ON SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
BOCA CHICA LAMB TRUCKED THE BIG
SUR LAND TRUSTS THE HOBBIT
DESERT MANTRA SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN SPACES THE ORKNEY
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS AND THE WILDLANDS
CONSERVANCY. OUT IN SUPPORT.
EXCEPT LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ETERNITY WITH
SIERRA BUSINESS COUNCIL THE
SIERRA CONSORTIUM AND THE
CALIFORNIA AWFUL LINE IN
SUPPORT. ANNEX'S LINE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING YOU ARE NOW TAKING PART
ON BEHALF OF THE EAST VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT WITH THE SUPPORT
AND THEN POSITION AND GRATEFUL
FOR SEPTIC TO SEWER LANGUAGE
THANK YOU. AND OUR WATER LINE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DAN WE CAN CAMP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR BIODIVERSITY SUPPORTING THE
BILL. AND NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
I'M NEXT- WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING TERRY
THIS AND MEMBERS- STEVEN MYERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS THE HOT SEAT
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION MID PENINSULA
pSAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION LAND TRUST OF SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY AND SERIES AND
SUPPORT IF AMENDED AS DESCRIBED
IN OUR SUBMITTED LETTERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU- ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION SEEN NONE OF
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS WHEN
WE START TALKING ABOUT BONDS
WHEN THE BEING CAUGHT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CALL IT A YET
ANOTHER WATER BOND- I THINK
SOMETHING THAT REALLY STRUCK ME
WAS THE FACT THAT. THE ONE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT SPOKE IN FAVOUR
MENTION THE FACT THIS IS
ALREADY BEEN PULLED SO THIS
MAKES US MORE OF A POLITICAL
MOVE ALMOST ANYTHING- BUT I'M
CURIOUS TO MY COLLEAGUES THAT
ARE BRINGING THIS FORWARD. IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN WITH.
PROPOSITION ONE THIS POST
REVISED SEVEN POINT FIVE
BILLION. MEMBERS WE'VE BEEN
HERE WE WE'VE TRIED TO WORKING
OVERSEE THIS WE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WERE PROMISED- SOME NEW
DAM SOME OTHER WATER PROJECTS
NEW JOBS. A LOT OF THE SAME
TALKING POINTS WE'RE HEARING
TODAY. WHERE IS THAT MONEY GONE
WAY OF THOSE JOBS GALLON IN
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THIS.
BECAUSE WE CONTINUE TO HEAR FOR
IN IN A COLLEAGUES BY MEMBERS
PRESENT AS I LOVE YOU GUYS I
LOVE WORKING WITH YOU BUT THE
SERIOUSLY. WHAT ARE WE DONE.
SINCE SINCE WE GOT IN OFFICE
NOW AND WHERE IS THIS GUY
BECAUSE WE SAW THIS AGAIN AND
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WE SAW THE
PUSH FOR PROPOSITION THREE.
EIGHT POINT NINE BILLION. HERE
TODAY WE'RE WE'RE ONLY ASKING
FOR SEVEN BILLION IN IN WHAT I
DON'T THINK THIS IS A MATTER OF
A PRICE TAG. BECAUSE MY AND MY
DEEPEST CONCERN IS THE FACT
THAT ONE LAST YEAR WHEN WE
STARTED SHUTTING DOWN OUR STATE
BECAUSE OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WE WERE TOLD WE WERE
GOING TO BE IN A RECESSION. WE
DID MASSIVE CUTBACKS WE DID ALL
OF THESE THINGS AND YET. TODAY
AS WE PREPARE TO HEAR THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE IT COMES
UP. WE KNOW THERE'S A PROJECTED
TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS.
B. FOREST SERVICE SO WHY SHOULD
WE GO BACK TO THE VOTERS. AND
ASK OF THEM. FOR ANOTHER BOND
WHEN WE JUST TOOK A SURPLUS OF
THEIR MONEY. IN IN WHAT ARE WE
DOING WITH THIS BECAUSE UNTIL
WE FIX YOU CALL RED TAPE YOU
CAN CALL GREEN TEA RIGHT INTEL
YOU FIX THE PROCESS. WITH HOW
THESE MONIES ARE ACTUALLY
CREATING THE DELIVERABLES THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT THESE JOBS
WE CLAIM THEY'RE GOING TO
CREATE. WHY SHOULD WHY SHOULD
ANY OF US SUPPORT THIS. BECAUSE
I BE ON THE LOOK WE CAN LIST
THE JOBS THAT'S GREAT WE NEED
TO DO THINGS FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
WE KNOW THAT WE WORK TOGETHER
ON THAT. WE TALK ABOUT NEW
RIDER PROJECTS WE TALK IF WE
PASSED LEGISLATION WE PUSH
THESE THINGS DAY IN AND DAY OUT
WE LOSE SLEEP OVER THE. BUT
WHERE IS THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT THAT WE KEEP TELLING
THE PUBLIC WE'RE GOING TO
DELIVER ON. WE CAN TALK CREAM
JOBS ALL DAY LONG. NATIONALS AT
IT. WHERE'S THE DELIVERABLES.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK YOU KNOW THE ANSWER TO
YOUR OWN QUESTION AND I THINK
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC TO- HERE AT THIS
DIALECT ONE MILLION REMAINS-
AVAILABLE FROM PROP NE FOR THE
PROJECTS THAT YOU MENTION I-THINK YOU ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
CHALLENGES OF MAKING THOSE
INVESTMENTS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
CONTINUE TO EXIST- WHETHER THEY
BE ENVIRONMENTAL AND OR OTHER
RELATED MATTERS RIGHT AND SO
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
TO. COLLECTIVELY WORK ON BUT- I
THINK THAT THIS SPECIFIC BOND-
THAT IS BEFORE YOU TODAY HAS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF BENEFITS
AND CO BENEFITS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
TO ADDRESS THE DROUGHT ISSUES
IN YOUR SPECIFIC AREA- THAT YOU
REPRESENT IN THE PORTABLE AREA
AND WE ALL RECOGNIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THAT EXISTING YOUR
SPECIFIC DISTRICT SO I MEAN TO
THE POINT OF- WHAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY- WHETHER YOU SUPPORTED
THIS BOND OR NOT TODAY YOU WILL
REAP SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS. FROM
INVESTMENTS GOING BACK TO YOUR
DISTRICT AS A RELIGIOUS MATTER
OUTSIDE YOUR CALLING MR GARCIA
WE WE'VE HEARD THIS TIME AND
AGAIN THIS THIS TURNS INTO
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA GET SOME
STUFF FOR YOUR DISTRICT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET SOME STUFF FOR
YOUR DISTRICT IN FOR YOUR
DISTRICT AND FOR YOUR DISTRICT
IN IN THE LAUNDRY LIST. OF
PROJECTS GOES ON AND ON. BY NO
MEANS AT THIS POINT IN TIME. DO
I THINK WE SHOULD CONTINUE A
LAUNDRY LIST OF PROMISES
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE THE LAUNDRY
LIST OF PROMISES. IN IN IN THE
FACE ALL OF THIS LANGUAGE. IS
THEIR SEQUEL EXEMPTION. FOR ALL
OF THESE PROJECTS FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT WE KNOW HAS TO GET
DONE. BUT YET THE READ THAT THE
TAPE THE BUREAUCRACY TIES IT UP.
WHERE IS THAT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
IN HERE. WHERE IS THE PROCESS
OR NOT SPENDING OVER 80% OF
THIS MONEY. ON GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERHEAD IN THREE HUNDRED PLUS
PAGE DOCUMENTS THAT THREE TO
FIVE AGENCIES HAVE TO GET JUST
TO GET THROUGH WHAT ONE STEP.
ALL OF THIS MONEY ALL IT
THEY'RE GREAT PROMISES BROUGH.
BUT WE'VE BEEN PROMISING THE
PUBLIC THIS STUFF FOR NEAR
DECADE. WHERE IS IT BE BECAUSE
YOU YOU CAN TELL ME THAT THIS
IS GONNA BE GREAT FROM MY
DISTRICT THIS IS GONNA BE GREAT
FOR YOUR TO. THE TALKING POINTS
ARE ON POINT. THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT AND I KNOW
WE ALL WANT TO SEE THEM. BUT
THIS DOES NOT CHANGE THE
PROCESS. OF DELIVERABLES. IT IS
WITH THAT SADLY I FEEL IT'S
ANOTHER FALSE PROMISE I KNOW WE
ALL WANT TO SEE IT WE'VE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT FOR OUR TEAM
HERE UP HERE. WHERE'S THE
DELIVERABLES BECAUSE THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE THE PROCESS IS
ANOTHER PROMISE. WILL OF- WE
NEED TO WORK ON A BILL RELATED
TO THE PROCESS I'M HAPPY TO-
YOU KNOW PARTNER UP WITH YOU
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE BEFORE YOU. TODAY
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
GREAT INVESTMENTS TO PLACES
LIKE YOURS AND OTHER LOCATIONS
IN THE STATE THAT NEEDS A SAFE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES. OUTLINED HERE NOT A
LAUNDRY LIST OF GIMMES ARE YOU
KNOW CHRISTMAS GIFTS BUT REAL
TANGIBLE INVESTMENTS THAT COULD
CHANGE CIRCUMSTANCES. UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING YOUR DISTRICT HAS A
RELEASE A SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER THANKS AGAIN MR GARCIA WE
WE'VE HAD THIS BEFORE. IN WHEN
I GOT ELECTED WE WHEN WE MATTER
FACT GOT ELECTED. IN THE
FOURTEEN ELECTIONS WE CAME IN
WE MADE PROMISES TO EACH OTHER
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO GO
AFTER THE STUFF I STILL TO THIS
DAY HAVE PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT
THAT LIVE IN THIRD WORLD
CONDITIONS. DUE TO WATER
BECAUSE OF FALSE PROBLEM.
PROMISES. FROM THIS BODY FROM
PREVIOUS BODIES OVER BONDS OVER
WE'RE GOING TO DO THESE THINGS
THE MONEY'S GOING TO COME. VOTE
WITH US WE'RE GONNA MAKE THIS
HAPPEN WE'RE GOING TO CREATE
THESE JOBS. THEY'RE STILL
LIVING IN THIRD WORLD
CONDITIONS. SO UNTIL THAT
PROCESS CHANGES AND WE CAN MAKE
GOOD ON THESE PROMISES. YOU CAN
TELL ME THIS IS GONNA BE GREAT
ALL DAY LONG. BUT UNTIL WE
ACTUALLY SEE A FEASIBLE CHANGE
IN THE POLICY TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN. VERSES RHETORIC.
ABSOLUTELY NOT. HEY MR STONE.
THANK YOU WHEN I CAN ASK YOU
WHERE PREVIOUS BONDS HAVE BEEN
SPENT THAT'S MY JOB TO FIGURE
OUT NOT YOURS ON ON THIS THEN
I'LL GIVE YOU A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF PROJECTS HAVE BEEN FUNDED BY
BOND MONEY IN THE PAST AND THAT
IS PROJECTS THAT ARE DONE
THROUGH THE INTEGRATED.
REGIONAL WATER. MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS. AND THOSE ARE
PROJECTS THAT. THAT I'M WORRIED
OR NOT REALLY INCLUDED IN HERE
BECAUSE OF. SOME OF THE LACK OF
SPECIFICITY IN THE LANGUAGE
AROUND THE WATER. AND WHY I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT. IS THIS
IS ABOUT RESILIENCE. BUT LOCAL
AGENCIES THROUGH THESE REGIONAL
PROGRAMS REGIONAL INTERESTS.
REGIONAL WHICH MEANS THAT
THEY'RE VETTED BY LOCAL
AGENCIES MULTIPLE LOCAL
AGENCIES. THESE ARE PROJECTS TO
BENEFIT HABITAT. THE BENEFIT
WATER SUPPLY THE BENEFIT
FISHERIES THAT HAVE TRULY
MULTIPLE BENEFITS. AND WE DON'T
THINK OF THESE PROGRAMS AS PART
OF THE RESILIENCE. BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN AROUND FOR A WHILE
WE'VE BEEN FUNDING THEM BUT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING RESILIENCE
FOR A LONG TIME. SO I JUST WANT
TO ASK AND- THIS GARCIA THANK
YOU WE GOT A AN ANSWER THIS
MORNING TOSOME QUESTIONS WE'VE
BEEN ASKING FOR A WHILE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- BUT I DISAGREE
THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THEIR
NECESSARILY COVERS THESE KINDS
OF PROGRAMS. SO THAT IS
SOMETHING I'M ASKING IF WE CAN
STRENGTHEN. BECAUSE THOSE ARE
TRUE RESILIENCE PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN HUGELY SUCCESSFUL
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN HELD UP BY
SEEK WITH IT HAVE NOT BEEN HELD
UP AND IT'S NOT. POLITICAL
RHETORIC BECAUSE THEY TAKE.
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVING TO VET
THEM. AMONGST EACH OTHER AND
WITH THE PUBLIC AND. AND SOME
VERY VERY SUCCESSFUL RESULTS IN
FORCING THE CENTRAL COAST BUT
REALLY ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE FUNDED THIS
PROGRAM THROUGH THESE BONDS
BEFORE THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT
IS HUGE AND DATE THESE ARE
REALLY VERY GOOD PROGRAM SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE. THAT WERE CLEAR THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS WILL BE ABLE TO
TAP INTO THESE TO THESE BONDS
AND CONTINUE THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING SOMEONE
UNDERSCORE AGAIN THESE ARE
RESILIENCE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN GOING ON LONG BEFORE
RESILIENCE BECAME SOMETHING
THAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
SO THAT'S MY ONLY ASK IS THAT
IS THAT YOU CONSIDER THOSE
PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY HAVE BOTH.
TO WATER SUPPLY AND TO THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THERE BUT
ALSO THE REGIONAL ASPECTS IN
REGIONAL ASPECTS. BENEFITS
OFFSHORE BENEFITS TO THE
FISHERIES AND OTHERS SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
FORGETTING THE PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL ALONG THE
WAY. AS WE ARE PUTTING TOGETHER
THIS NEW BOND SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT THANK YOU MRS ON IF I MAY
JUST RESPONDED THAT WE
CERTAINLY ARE OPEN TO- BE MORE
SPECIFIC WHEN IT COMES TO THE-
LANGUAGE RELATED TO THE
INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN WE RECEIVE SOME
FEEDBACK FROM OTHER. PARTS OF
STATE WHERE THIS PROCESS HAS
WORKED YEAH- YOU KNOW INITIALLY
WE LOOKED AT THIS AND SEE IN
THE SECTION OF REGIONAL CLIMATE
ADAPTATION- SPECIFICALLY TO
ADDRESSING RESILIENCY RIGHT-
THERE'S- A HUNDRED FIFTY.
MILLION DOLLARS IN THAT AREA
BUT- IF THE NEED TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC- IN TERMS OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE- I. R. W.
ENDS UP WILL. DEFINITELY KEEP
THAT IN MIND AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU THAT'S MY ASK OUR
PROJECT. THANK YOU MISTER-
DOCTOR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I WOULD TO SAY IT SAY THANK YOU
THE AUTHORS AROUND THE FIRE
SECTIONS- THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES FOR PRE
HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT PROGRAM
PREVENT WILDFIRES REDUCE THE
RISK OF WILDFIRES TO
COMMUNITIES BY INCREASING
COMMUNITY HARDENING. THANK YOU-
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO THE REGIONAL FIRE FORCE
CAPACITY PROGRAM TO INCREASE
REGIONALS A CAPACITY PRIORITIZE
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT PROJECTS
THAT IMPROVE FOREST HEALTH AND
FIRE RESILIENCE THANK YOU THESE
ARE BOTH. THOSE THAT WE'VE BEEN
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON MY OFFICE.
A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO DEPARTMENT FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION TO SUPPORT VARIOUS
LONG TERM FOR STILL PROJECTS I
WAS ALSO THAT WAS. OUT OF S. B.
NINE A ONE I THANK YOU. WHAT I
DO WANT TO ASK YOU TO CONSIDER-%
IS- SOMETHING AROUND CANNABIS-
CLEANUP- PROP SIXTY FOUR.
PROMISED TO MONEY TO HELP CLEAN
UP THE ENVIRONMENT FROM ILLEGAL
CANNABIS GROWS AND- IT'S NOT
ENOUGH. AND MATTER OF FACT IS
JUST BARELY TRICKLING IN AT
THIS POINT- THE INITIATIVE WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
LEGALIZATION HAPPEN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THESE TRESPASS GROWS
HAVE CONTINUED TO GROW AND
PULLED PROLIFERATE THEY DO
INCREDIBLE ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE
TO OUR WATERSHEDS OUR
BIODIVERSITY. ENDANGERED
SPECIES AND MUCH MORE. WHETHER
WE DO THIS AS A DIRECT
APPLICATION ALLOCATION TO D. F.
TO A D. TO THE DFW FUND OR- OR
MAKE CANNABIS CLEAN UP AN
ELIGIBLE EXPENSE- IN THE OTHER
WATERSHED FOCUSED PROGRAMS I
THINK WOULD BE A WERE THE USE
OF THIS. OF THESE FUNDS. SO IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO CONSIDER THIS
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU WE KNOW THIS ISSUE
WELL. WE'VE DEALT WITH THIS
ISSUE IT WAS ONE OF MY DRIVING
FORCES FOR WORKING ON. THE
MEDICAL CANNABIS REGULATORY
SAFETY ACT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN-
INCREDIBLE DAMAGE BEING DONE TO
OUR WATERSHEDS. ON IN THIS YEAR
IN A DROUGHT SITUATION WE'RE
EXPECTING THAT THEY'LL BE A LOT
OF ILLEGAL DIVERSIONS- FOR. FOR
ROAD CANNABIS GROWS- OF WATER
IN A DROP. THAT IS GOING TO
AFFECT US ALL IN A REALLY
REALLY SIGNIFICANT HUESO DEATH
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISH TO SPEAK. AT THE
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'VE BEEN DOING- INVOLVED IN
DOING ON THIS- N. AS AS THE
WORK CONTINUES I HAVE INTERESTS
AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE A
DEFINING- PARK POOR
NEIGHBORHOODS- AND- I HAVE
INTEREST IN. HOW WE START TO
PUT SOME ADDITIONAL GUARDRAILS
ARE INFORMATION AROUND THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION TO THE STATE
WATER BOARDS IN THE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR WATER BIRDS ON THE
WATER CONTAMINATION AND CLEAN
WATER ISSUES. I DO APPRECIATE
THAT MONEY- AND SO IT'S NOT A
COMPLAIN IT'S MY DISCUSSES
DETAILS MOVE ON ONE OF THE
ISSUES WE SAW IT AS WE WANT TO
HAVE SOME OF THOSE DEFINITIONS.
MADE IT TO THAT'S ON MY LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES STILL THAT
I'M QUALIFY ON AND SUGGESTED
EARNING FROM THAT FOR A LITTLE
MORE NEW ONES ALONG THE WAY-
AND SO I DO APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT'S- THAT YOU'RE DOING ON
THIS- WE HAVE A LOT OF EMERGING
CHEMICALS INCLUDING P. FILES.
THAT JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PREPARED FOR THAT-
AND WHILE WE CAN'T THINK OF
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE LIVING
ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY IN THAT
LANGUAGE AWAY WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS ON THE ROAD-
AND SO. THANK YOU. HEY MISTER
FLOOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR- GENTLEMAN I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
JUST HAVE ONE QUICK QUESTION I
JUST DIG INTO ONE PARTICULAR-
SECTION THERE'S FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS- TO CDFA AS IT RELATES
TO- METHANE EMISSION REDUCTION
FOR DAIRY LIVESTOCK. DOES THAT
INCLUDE OR EXCLUDE DIED
YESTERDAY. IT I GUESS YOURS
WOULD BE- ELIGIBLE WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT OUT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS- WON'T GO VERY
FAR CORRECT WHEN IT COMES TO
ADDRESSING THE SPECIFIC ISSUE
OF BY TESTERS IN THE STATE SO
RIGHT NOW THAT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS WILL NOT JUST BE GOING
THROUGH A MMP CURVE MMP BUT IT
ELIGIBLE FOR DIGESTIVE AS WELL
CORRECT THAT'S THE WAY I
UNDERSTAND IT YES. OKAY BECAUSE
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE TALKED
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT I MEAN
THROUGH THE- LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS THROUGH CARB. CDFA YOU
KNOW ALL PREVIOUSLY
HISTORICALLY ALLOCATIONS OF
MONIES TO THOSE AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL. MR
STONE IS BROUGHT DOWN TO A
POINT FORWARD I THOUGHT WAS
VERY VERY- LIKE WE CANNOT
FORGET ABOUT THE PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THE
PAST RIGHT NOW METHANE DIED
YESTERDAY. REDUCE UP TO FORTY
PERCENT. OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
AS FAR AS METHANE PRODUCTION
WITHIN- CATTLE AND DAIRY. SO I
AM JUST VERY VERY CONCERNED
THAT IF THAT IS NOT ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR. BECAUSE WE WENT THROUGH
THIS AN ATTIC- COMMITTEE A FEW
WEEKS OR LAST WEEK. AND SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION TO THIS- IS
REALLY REALLY AGGRESSIVE. AND
THEY'RE REALLY REALLY LOUD. AND
IF WE ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
METHANE REDUCTION GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION CO TWO REDUCTION
WE CANNOT. JUST PICK AND CHOOSE
WHAT TECHNOLOGIES WE WANT THIS
MONEY TO BE AVAILABLE WE HAVE
TO USE BEST PRACTICES. AND
RIGHT NOW I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH YOU FORTY MILLION IS
SIGNIFICANTLY ON I'D LOVE TO
SEE A CLOSER TO A HUNDRED. AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET IT THERE-
IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS IN HIS
BUDGET AS WELL. BUT I DO WANT
SOME SORT OF COMMITMENT THAT AS
THIS THING MOVES FOR BECAUSE I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING
PIECES RIGHT NOW- YOU KNOW
COMING OUT OF THAT COMMITTEE AS
WELL THAT YOU'RE WORKING WITH
ON THE CHAIR. JERRY THIS. IS
THERE A COMMITMENT THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE IN LANGUAGE. THAT
METHANE DIGESTION ARE INCLUDED.
IN THIS FUNDING. IT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT AND
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU AND
OTHERS THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
SEEING THAT. AMOUNT INCREASE.
AND TALK ABOUT THE SPECIFICS IN
THE LANGUAGE FOR PURPOSES OF
ELIGIBILITY WE TO. AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS ARE LOOKING TO- THIS
SURPLUS THAT'S BEFORE US TO SEE
HOW FAR WE CAN STRETCH OUT.
SOME OF THOSE INVESTMENTS THAT
THAT WILL ALIGN WITH THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAVE.
BEFORE US TODAY BUT THE I THINK
THE CORE OF YOUR QUESTION IS.
CAN WE DO MORE IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT- WE CERTAINLY ARE OPEN
TO THAT. AND THE SECOND PART OF
YOUR QUESTION IS THE ISSUE OF
THE TECHNOLOGIES AND WILL
CERTAINLY- THEY FOCUSED ON
THAT. PART AS WELL IN THE COR
MY QUESTION AND WE'VE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS AS I WANT TO
STOOP TO USE BEST PRACTICES.
AND THE AND WE AS A ANALECTA
BODY. IT'S OUR JOB TO GO FIND
OUT FUNDING. SO ARE AGENCIES
CAN GO DO THEIR JOBS. AND THEY
ARE THE EXPERTS AT THIS AND SO
I THINK WE SHOULD- WORK WITH
THEM AND WORK WITH BEST
PRACTICES I'M GONNA LAY OFF OF
THIS TODAY BUT I ABSOLUTE FOR
IF WE GET SOME OF THESE THINGS
FIXED. TO SUPPORT IT ON THE
FLOOR- BUT I WOULD- APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THANK YOU. ARE THERE
OTHER. QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. CASEIN NONE I'M WILL
YOU BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WE SET CERTAINLY
WELL WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THEM
MINUTES THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
AND YOUR TEAM'S WORK IN THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD YOU KNOW- WE ALL HAVE
SEEN THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN OUR COMMUNITIES- AND
WE NEED INVESTMENTS THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO TAKE ACTION AND
THIS BOND I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BOND DOES THAT. AS ONE OF THE
WITNESSES MENTIONED- YOU KNOW
HEAT RELATED EVENTS ARE A MORE
EXTREME AND HAVE HAPPENED
ESPECIALLY AND MY PART OF THE
STATE- AND THAT'S SOMETHING I'M
VERY INTERESTED IN AND
MITIGATING THAT HEAT UP SO
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING OUR
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. JUST A QUICK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
IN THE COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS
I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE-
ENTERTAINING THIS I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT I
APPRECIATE THAT MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER MATHIS IS. RECOGNITION
OF THE SURPLUS ENVIRONMENT THAT
WE'RE IN WE ARE VERY MINDFUL OF
THAT AS WELL. WE CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT A NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS
CAN BE MADE WITH CLASS- CLIMATE
RESILIENCE IN MIND IN THIS
BUDGET CYCLE- SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
MORE APPROPRIATELY FUNDED
THROUGH BOND- FINANCING BUT
JUST. LOOK AT THE MAGNITUDE OF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TALK ABOUT SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR
BOND. I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
TWENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
JUST MY COUNTY. IS AT RISK. SO
THIS IS A- ALL OF THE ABOVE
KIND OF A STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH
A GENERATIONAL. CHALLENGE THE
MAGNITUDE TO WHICH WE ARE JUST
NOW WRAPPING OUR HEADS AROUND.
FROM A STATEWIDE. BASIS I
CERTAINLY HOPE. THAT THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL PUMP SOME
MONEY INTO INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
COULD DRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED TODAY- BUT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE ALL OF THAT. UP ROBUST
ACTION ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
ROBUST ACTION EACH BUDGET CYCLE
COMING FORWARD AND- THE BOND
PIECE OF THIS. ALONG WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANOTHER APPROACH IS
TO- BEGIN TO DEAL WITH THIS-
CHALLENGE SO- WITH THAT A SENSE
OF URGENCY- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU. I DON'T
BELIEVE I HAVE A MOTION. OKAY I
HAVE A MOTION FROM MISTER WHAT
SECONDED BY MISS GARCIA. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS I'M SECRETARY
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
ONE A. B. FIFTEEN HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS EDUARDO GARCIA
AND MULLIN. MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVAS III FLOOR FLOOR NOT
VOTING CHILD FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA ZERO I. MATHIS
MATHIS NOW MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
RIGHT TO G. I.'S THE ONLY THEY
ARE CHAU NUMBER THEY ARE NOT
VOTING STONE. STONE I WOULD
WOULD I. SIX ONE SIX ONE THAT
BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY. WE'LL
LEAVE- THE ROLE OPEN I THINK
THERE'S A FEW MEMBERS THAT WANT
TO COME IN AT ON. THANK.
WE
HAVE MISTER CHOW HERE. HUMAN
ONE ITEM ONE A. B. FIFTEEN
HUNDRED BY MEMBERS I'D RATHER
GARCIA AND MULLIN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE IS SIX TO ONE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU CHOW I'D- SEVEN
ONE
. SEVEN ONE. LIFTING THE
CALL ON ITEM ONE AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED BY MEMBERS ARE JOB
LARGO GARCIA AND MULLIN MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CURRENT GOAL IS SEVEN TO ONE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBER MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
EIGHT ONE. EIGHT ONE THE BILL
IS OUT AND MEETING IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.